mich mega hassig mich einfach mega
[Musik]
verletzte
ich versuche und nicht dass sie dann
komplett allein
zwei von fünf
[Musik]
erwachsen sind
ich frage mich was für Einfluss hat
[Musik]
das macht mich mega traurig und
irgendwie glaube ich oder Hoffi auch
dass es vielleicht zu viel neustarken
natürlich nicht einfach gesehen Gründer
und das ist eigentlich immer noch klar
für mich aber irgendwie sind zu fragen
wie war das für meine Kind falls
nach langem überlege kann ich mich
entschieden dafür nichts machen ich habe
festgestellt dass viel wenn Sie es
wahrscheinlich
ältere trendt ihre
[Musik]
älteren
so viel Spannung und schwarz und Druck
und alles die Heike und ich bin halt
mich nicht gut daran auf mich
konzentriert und auf mich Studium und
ich kann mich auch einfach mega
verantwortlich gefühlt
und ja dass ich einfach alles fehlt
und wie fühlt sich jetzt an
jetzt mega gut jetzt ist
weggeklappt aber mit der neue
familiesituation noch hat sie sich noch
nicht so auffreunde aber wenn sie weiß
dass es für Beziehung von der älteren
wahrscheinlich besser so ist
ja ich finde es
jetzt halt im Moment noch und ich glaube
sie findet auch schwierig also es findet
einfach alle nur schwierig es ist
komische Situationen ich einfach
ja sich mega komisch wenn wir irgendwie
alle sind so in deinem Konstrukt
aufgewacht also wie es Kind
Familie und dann ist es plötzlich
einfach nimmer und die Beziehung wurde
ältere Spritze einfach mit einem
vorhanden ich einfach weg
also mir ist es vorher nicht so bewusst
wie fest mich das auch mitnimmt ich
hatte Angst ich werde den Schuh
Erwachsene
sich halt aber das kann man vielleicht
auch von der Familie trennen so
Liebesbeziehung und Familie und Gott
halt irgendwie nicht
ich finde das eigentlich nur ein
wichtiger Punkt wo ich selber wie auch
merkt kann
es wird immer gesagt
ich bin mega froh dass ich in gute
Kindheit gehabt und dass das jetzt
passiert ist aber trotzdem wir sind
gleich
zum Teil auch Musik Gefühl mega
unterdrückt also ist am Anfang
mega verletzt
und das heißt dann eigentlich
zum älteren nicht aber zum Eltern nicht
verletzten
[Musik]
geburtstag
ich da das so sich so einfach schnürt
alles und sich so eng auffiel
wir machen
viele Emotionen
wenn ich aber so Moment habe wo alles
wieder kommt hilft mir sehr mich mit
meiner Freundin und mein Freund zu
treffen
und mich einfach abzunehmen
[Musik]
die bezieht und sehen
und ich merke immer mehr dass es aber
doch wichtig wäre alles was mir passiert
ist aufzuarbeiten
entschädigt von der älteren viel
psychische narbehinderung
[Musik]
und ja ich glaube also man hat eine
Quelle Hilfe abhüter man kann selber
hilft braucht also
ich persönlich Verantwortung
[Musik]
aber ich glaube
verwendet das Problem dass es dann
natürlich du bist ein Problem
zu sprechen sind
ältere und die ganze Zeit und dumme
Hände sehr prägt wissen sie Punkt ist es
nicht gegangen und der dominik hat
psychologische Hilfe kalt ist aufgrund
von einer sogenannten generalisierte
Angststörung behandelt wurde
unverhofft richtig Glückseligkeit in
mein Leben sie lässt nicht meine Fehler
und Sorgen verschwinden das schenk mir
den Willen es zu versuchen durch sie
werden nicht meine Sorgen abklingen
durch dank ihr werdet
doch hier bin ich geduldig sie gibt mir
zu verstehen was Akzeptanz bedeutet ich
habe immer genügend Zeit mir selbst zu
verstehen zu geben dass ich würdig bin
so wie es jeder Mensch ist
polnische Emotionen aus der Nähe also
ich glaube das hat jetzt in der
Vergangenheit aber gesagt
und
das hat da nicht einen Moment ab und
zwar
im
dominiken
Brustbereich und weitere körperliche
Beschwerden
seine Gedanken
sind extrem über das
Verletzung
fühlt sich schlecht
und ja eigentlich was gefühlt habe
und nicht dass sie dann komplett leicht
minimiert mich Vorwurf gemacht
aber ich kann
[Musik]
der Dominik
Freundin sich vor kurzem erst trennten
genau erfahren
[Musik]
bei ID einfach mühsel loslegen
als Kind hätte Dominik Quellen
Verantwortung über hat das aber nicht
können mit dem kann ich mich gut
identifizieren
ich war irgendwie ausständig Gefühl ich
muss stark sie für mich
Geschwister die und
ich glaube das ist doch wieder
Unterschied wenn es das Kind passiert
wir werden es als Erwachsene passiert
ich Heu ja die Verantwortung über Nacht
oder ich heuer ausstarch sie und haben
einfach wie gemerkt dass man wirklich
muss aufpassen dass man sich selber
nicht vergisst und dass man auch darf
also auch nicht immer muss stark sein
und einfach einmal dafür dass es einem
nicht so gut geht obwohl Training von
meine älteren schon vier Jahren ist das
Thema nur sehr interessant die letzte
Jahr sind es emotional suchen und
abgesehen der Verkauf vom älteren Haus
hat sehr viel mit loslassen
mit der Situation das
Familienkonstellation jetzt anders
aber dass man als Erwachsene zwei
Verantwortung aber vielleicht nicht
immer
[Musik]
ich treffe mich noch mal mit dem Mira
und komme mit ihrer heigutznacht essen
ich finde mich die High immer noch schön
so ja
kein Ort
hallo
hi
ich tue jetzt ein bisschen vergessen
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass du vielleicht
dann
aber normal
sind heute eigentlich alle da
ihre Mutter hat sich entschieden nicht
vor der Kamera über zitationsreden es
ist alles nur sehr frisch
es zeigt
Familie Mitglied
[Musik]
miteinander
und ja
jetzt das plötzlich so alle Maxi sind
schon ab und zu uns
auch meine
und wie machen
die Stimmung
ja genau
schön und alles aber wenn es da wirklich
zu
anfangs ziemlich gut und ja
[Musik]
schwer weil es für mich ganz sehr
emotional gesehen
ich merke wie dass es für mich
auch und Prozess ist wenn ich alles
verarbeite und bitte mir auch
dass mir sehr viel ähnliche Gedanken sie
für ähnliche
Problematiken und
ja irgendwie die Familie in jetzt
gesehen wo man gespürt da ist
alles verdaut verarbeitet ist für mich
ein mega spezielles
krasse e-fluss
die Beziehung von der Eltern
das beschäftigt mich immer mehr ich
werde Hoffnungen
also als ich sie getroffen habe am
Anfang weiß man das ja noch nicht so
aber danach relativ bald ja es hätte
mehr aber nicht so kommuniziert
natürlich
ich wollte mal schauen wie sie darauf
reagiert ob sich das halt dann ändert
über die Zeit weil ich das halt gesehen
habe dass es relativ schnell abfallen
kann wenn man verheiratet ist und ich
wollte einfach mal schauen ob sie es ist
ein bisschen Druck und das ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen fies
gewesen weil einfach zu sehen und dann
weiter dabei bleiben möchtest oder nicht
schwierig oder speziell dass sie ja
beides Kinder sind hätte das auch die
Entscheidung
was ist sicher nicht Baby sicher
okay
tja
ich merke vor allem wieder ja dass sie
Training von der älteren viel mit ihrer
Macht oft kennt ihr die älteren auch der
Training Wagen finanziellen gestritten
und auch als Kind hat sie viel Stück
drei Jahre erlaubt
ich habe probiert romantisch
gesehen sehr herzlich
und wir hätten
oh schön
[Gelächter]
aber jetzt die Frage
immer so alles hinterfragt und
kompliziert gemacht und keine Ahnung
[Musik]
ich habe
aufgewachsen bin
macht mit dem Bild vor der Ehe und
Beziehung
fotografiere ist halt passiert das ist
eine Hochzeit
und ähm das hat mir
Jonas
so viel Menschen haben wo so große Liebe
voneinander haben
[Musik]
also ich hoffe natürlich nicht und ich
Bezüge mir schaffe es natürlich und für
die Tür oder man weiß es halt nicht und
ich wünsche dir dass wenn wir uns würde
mal entscheiden wo das muss dann
muss es einfach Vertrag
für unsere Kinder
ich will einfach nicht ich will das
nicht Familie
für unsere Kinder und ich hoffe
die beiden so verliert sehen und voller
Hoffnung und
es hat schon outside dass das Film mit
denen macht viel Gedanken wo sich andere
wo bleibt das nicht erlaubt sind
aber es zeigt mir aber das ist auch die
sich gibt die Hoffnung wo da ist dass
man einfach zusammen schafft und
zusammen zu dem Schluss runter dass mir
das Wetter
unbedingt die Kommentar freue mich mega
für ihre Aktionen und wenn er nicht wenn
verpassen dann abonniert unbedingt den
Kanal